you're looking at bumper-to-bumper
traffic
outside a food bank in dallas over the
weekend where volunteers handed out
groceries
including 5 000 turkeys ahead of the
thanksgiving holiday
researchers from northwestern university
estimate food insecurity in america
doubled in the first few months after
the coronavirus arrived
a recent cbs news poll shows more than
one third of americans are at least
somewhat concerned they won't have
enough money for
groceries in the next year errol barnett
reports now on the growing need
before the holidays alrighty thank you
so much have a good thanksgiving
it's a scene playing out across the
country jam-packed food banks like
this one in arlington texas which
provided thanksgiving meals for five
thousand families it's just crazy to see
the turnout
and it's crazy to see the love you know
that we so desperately need
lee cowan spoke to hungry families in
san antonio for sunday morning
including catherine nguyen a mother of
five who lost her job as a housekeeper
during the pandemic
you have to like decide if you're going
to pay a bill or not
or decide to go get groceries and maybe
your water your lights might get turned
off the next month or something
in atlanta on sunday people waited for
hours after tyler perry announced he
would give away
thanksgiving supplies and gift cards at
his studio to the first
five thousand families traffic backed up
for miles
the event began at 8 a.m and the studio
ran out of groceries
by 10 a.m
in los angeles aldolfo escobar also
waited hours to pick up his holiday
groceries
it's not easy i lost my job i had
like four months with no income food
insecurity disproportionately affects
black and latino americans
especially those with kids as the need
grows
nationwide some volunteers are noticing
another trend
many of the cars you see coming through
here this pandemic is the first time
they've ever called for help
an analysis from the hunger relief
organization feeding america projects
more than 50 million americans will have
experienced
food insecurity this year that's up from
around 35 million before the pandemic
what the pandemic did was push people
from poverty and hunger
deeper and push people at the edge into
hunger and poverty
joel berg is ceo of the non-profit
advocacy group
hunger free america this is the worst
hunger crisis
in modern american times unless the
federal government does something big
and quick we're going to see starvation
conditions like this country hasn't seen
since the great depression
for cbs this morning i'm errol barnett
some really striking numbers there 50
million americans
and and what's also interesting is as
errol pointed out a lot of people in
this situation for the first time
yes indeed you're never working that's
what's working your whole life
working your life saving doing
everything right exactly and you find
yourself in that position there's tyler
perry once again
stepping in to help but to hear that it
opened at eight by ten
they see that kind of demand that finds
out how dire it is
yeah for so many people